abone ol
[Alkış]
e Herkese merhabalar Çok iyi bir
mutlulukla hayatta yapmayı en çok
sevdiğim şey sunum olarak TED konuşması
Hoş geldiniz etmekten büyük mutluluk
duyuyorum
Bugün sizlerle hayatta adım atmama büyük
destek sağlayan iki taştan bahsedeceğim
bir tanesi Az önce ismini söylediğim
sunum sunumla birlikte nereden geldiğimi
nereye gittiğimi neler yaptığını ve
nasıl yaptığımı da sizlerle yine
paylaşıyor olacağım nereden geldiğiniz
çok önemli neler öğrendiğimiz çok önemli
başarıdan bahsettik başarı nedir bu
Konsept tanımak hayatta Belki de ilk
önce ilk adımlarımızı attığımızda Aferin
oluyoruz yemeğimizi bitirdiğimizde sonra
okula başlıyoruz sınavları katılıyoruz
notlar alıyoruz sonra iş hayatına
katılıyoruz ve başarının ne demek oldu
Belki de anam değiştirmeye başlar ve bir
karmaşa içerisine giriyoruz
benim başarıyla olan Hikayem Gerçekten
birazcık şanslı oldu çünkü çocuk olarak
her O çok sevindim
büyük bir ailenin içinden geldim
sevginin paylaşıldığı konuşulduğu
birbirine iletildiği büyük bayramlar
kalabalık sofralar bu yaşıma kadar hala
böyle güzel bir ailenin parçası olmaktan
gurur duydum ve mutluluk duydum nereden
geldiğimiz nasıl bir halde olduğumuz
hepimiz için çok çok önemli her ne kadar
bir adım önde başlamış olsam da böyle
güzel bir ailenin içinde olmaktan birçok
şeyi de yine kendiniz karar veriyoruz
bugünkü daha önce konuşmalarda karardan
eve nasıl hayatımızda isteyeceğim sizden
bahsetmiştik
uzun sofralar büyük sohbetler gerektirdi
insanlarla tanışmak onlarla nasıl sohbet
edilir ilgilerini çeker nelerden
bahsedilir sofralarda bunlar aslında
çocuk olsak bile Networking dediğimiz
çevremizi geliştirmenin en önemli
yeteneklerinden bir tanesi olduğunu
yavaş yavaş farkediyor olmuştum şu
kameranın her zaman arkasındayım şu ana
kadar şu anda sahip olmaktan bir
bulduysam da kameralarında bu topluluk
insanda önceden böyle değildi daha çok
kaydetmeyi Çayeli takip etmeyi İnsanları
tanımayı neler söylediklerini kaynağı
almayı çok çok severek yaptım
hikayeler dediğimiz Aslında aramızda Bu
salonda bulunan izleyiciler arasında
bizi izleyenler arasında herkesin farklı
bir hikayesi var ve hepsinin de
dinlenmesi gerektiğine içerisinden çok
büyük çıkarımlar sağlanabileceğini
inanıyorum hikâyelerle olan
bilim
deneyelim kısa filmlerle başladı Bir de
nereden Geldiğimden bahsedeyim Annem
İstanbullu babam Bayburtlu evlendikten
sonra annem de Bayburt'u kendi iyiymiş
gibi sahiplenerek
doğduğumdan beri Bayburt'a sık sık gidip
gelmeye başladık Burada da fotoğrafta
gördüğünüz önce benim arkada
kuzenlerimle birlikte bir kısa film
çalışmasında Bayburt'un güzel
ovalarından bir tanesinde çekimler
yapmaya başladık kullandığımda tabi bana
Hayır diyemedi İyi onlar da beni
oyuncularımı almış oldu farklı
hikâyelerden bahsettik İzmir'de
kisa-filmler çektik engelli
arkadaşlarımızın sosyal hayat içerisinde
ne gibi nelerle karşılaştığını anlatmaya
başladık daha sonra filmlerden de
ilerleyip sosyal sorumluluk projeleri
adım atmaya başladım Yine lisedeyken
farklı bir Kısa Film Yarışması ile
birlikte 16000 ilkokul öğrencisinin
hayallerini gerçekleştirmeyi başardı ve
burada anladım ki sunum dediğimiz şey
doğru yapıldığı zaman karşısındakini
doğru adımlar atmasını çok kolay bir
şekilde sağlayabiliyor Tabi bunu
yaparken verdiğiniz mesaj nasıl
veriyorsunuz karşınızdaki insan almak
istediği mesaj nedir çok önemli her ne
kadar sizin amacınız çok önemli olsa da
belki dünyanın en önemli bilgisini
paylaşıyordu olsanız Eğer karşınızdaki
için verimli bir çıkarım yoksa
verdiğiniz mesajında anlamı tamamen
getirilmiş oluyor Bununla birlikte yeni
lisedeyken dönemin ağzına kulübüne
katıldım
videoları severken dedim ki de farklı
bir sunum yapalım
bu
konseptini tanırken büyürken
başarısızlık Konsept ile de tanıştım bu
fotoğrafın çekildiği gün tarihinin belki
de en kötü münazarasında ben yaparak
listenizin münazarayı kaybetmesine sebep
oldu ve bu Tabii ki bir adım geri atmama
sebep oldu ama küslük dediğimiz şey
başarısızlık dediğimiz şey gerçekten
doğru ortam verildiği zaman çok kolay
bir şekilde yeniden yenilenebiliyor Ben
de bu konuda çok şanslıydım her ne kadar
bana Kimse gelip de bu saatten sonra
olmaz sen bunu yapamadım münazara
yapamıyorsun demedi ise de çevremde çok
insanın bununla karşılaştığını gördüm
belki kariyerin değiştirmek isteyenlere
Hayır bu saatten sonra olmaz il
değiştirmek isteyenlere bölümünü
değiştirmek isteyenlere Herkese bu
saatten sonra olmaz Dandini çok fazla
duydum ben de diyorum ki bu saatten
sonra rahat rahat olur hiçbir şey için
hiçbir zaman geç olmadığını öğrendim
gördüm ve birebir tanık oldum bu
motivasyona sahip olduktan sonra
istersek lise öğrencisi olalım
üniversite emekli olmuş olalım
Karadenizin ortasında olalım ve
istediğimiz renk büyük motivasyon ımıza
noktasında ise biz be noktasında yasak O
noktaya gitmek için kimsenin Bizim
karşımızda Duran olması gerekiyor benim
ayet hissetmemi sağlayacak yer yeniden
sahne oldu üniversiteye katıldığım zaman
tiyatro Kulübü'nün katıldım ve
seyircilerle yeniden buluşma şansım oldu
gerçekten çok güzel bir ekiple güzel
performanslar gerçekleştirdik her ne
kadar başta utangaçlığımı kırılmamış
olsam ve seçimler yapılırken en küçük
rolü almış olsam da saniye çıktıkça
insanlar bu rolü geldikçe benim önümde
kendiliğinden büyümeye başladı
Dolayısıyla elime verilmiş olan şey
büyüdü ve benim sunumlarla izleyicilerle
sizlerle olan güzel bir yaşamın başlamış
oldu tığı sadece tiyatroyla kalmadı
güzel başka paylaşımlarında birazdan
olacak
başlangıç yaptıktan sonra coğrafya benim
coğrafyam ikiye ayrıldı teknik kadar da
olsa Londra İngiltere yerleştikten Sonra
üniversite hayatı başlamış oldu ama aynı
zamanda bir şey daha oldu bu
bulunduğumuz oradan geldiniz Bayburt'ta
babamın ailesi ile birlikte göç ettikten
sonra çocuklarına eğitim verebilmek
amacıyla göç ettikleri bayburt'tan bir
geri dönüş isteği vardı büyük Aile
olduğumuz için büyük sofralar az önce de
paylaştım sizlerle bir ev gerekiyordu ve
bizde bunu yaptık sağ tarafta gördüğünüz
babam babaannem Anneannem Teyze ben
annem Fatma Hanım bu da arkada
gördüğünüz aileniz inşa ettik Şimdi Alev
inşa ettik ama aslında önümüzde çok
farklı bir yolculuk vardı ve biz bunu
nereye gittiğini gerçekten bilmiyorduk
hepimize sürpriz oldu bir yanlar
Londra'daki eğitime devam ederken bir
yandan da bayramlarımızı yazılarımızı
Bayburt'ta Beşpınar luhan yukarı lü
köyünde geçirmeye devam ettik bunu
yaparken evimizin bahçesinde Bir tane de
anfi tiyatro inşa ettik bunu da sebebi
şuydu Tamam anılarından bahsederken
şöyle söyledi Ben çocukken sinemaya
gitmek Bayburt merkezde bir tane zaten
seni arar köyden oraya git Bu açık Bir
kamyonun arkasında dört saatlik bir
yolculuğun tekabül ediyor O da eğer ki
dedesinin cebinden birkaç bozuk para
bulabilirse sinemayı karşılayabilmek
için onu yaşadığı için o köy
çocuklarının bunu yaşamasını istemedi ve
dedi ki bahçemizde biraz patrişa edelim
buraya çocuklar için sinema geceleri
zaman elime bizde bunu yaptık tabi
sahibi olduğu zaman Bayburtlu
tanıdıklarınız varsa varsa gelmişsiniz
bilirsiniz ki o sahneyi çok güzel
doldururlar halaylar çekilir türküler
söylenir müzik geceleri yaşanır Biz de
aynısını yaptık böyle olduğu zaman bizim
evimiz ailemiz birden bire Kültür Evi
kaynana geldi Çeşitli türküler
sanatçılar geldiler eserlerini
sergilediler müziklerini dinletiler
yemekler yendi coğrafyanın yemekleri
yendi ve birdenbire Biz kendimizi
Aslında coğrafyanın Merkezi
noktalarından biri olarak bulmuş olduk
uzun sofralarımız yine devam etti
arkamda görmüş olduğunuz evde yine
babamın doğmuş fakat göç ettikten sonra
zamanla kaybolmuş köy evi bu Kevin olan
bu ile birlikte yine bahçemize aynı evin
replikası birebir inşa ettik ve buna bir
Anadolu evinin örneği olmuş oldu
dolayısıyla Kültür Evi olarak
başladığımız bu yolculuk birden bire Biz
aslında bir müze yolculuğuna doğru
ilerlemeye başladı arkamda gördüğünüz
yine babaannem ve annem onlarında
yaptığı çok başarılı bir şey var da
misafirperverlik şimdi bahçemizde bir
amfitiyatro var Yalan sinema geceleri
düzenleniyor bir yandan bir sergi salonu
kurduk bahçede çok ufak 50 metrekarelik
ve buraya birçok insanın çöpe attığı ya
da evin arka gizli köşelerinde sakladığı
üzerine başka eşyalar koyduğu asla
tarihi eser niteliğinde olan eserlere
bize örnek örnek olarak Eğer vererek
sergilemeye başladık Ve bu eserleri
oraya bağırsağın insanların isimlerini
yazarak hikayelerini de yine
ziyaretçilerimize dinlemeye başladık
Babaanneme Annem de tüm genelleri
sofralarına ağırladılar baba Annem bugün
Hala biz resmi dilimize olsak da tüm
ziyaretçilerin o zaman ederek sofrasına
davet ediyor Biz de Elimizden geleni
yapmaya çalışıyoruz
misafirperverlik demişken sunum yeniden
devam etmeye başladı müze olma yolunda
ilerlerken etkinliklerimiz şu aldı gerek
hasatı gösterdik gerek vardı Nasıl
çalışır onu gösterdik yöresel yemekler
yapılır Nasıl yapılır onu gösterdik
yerel halkla birlikte yaptığımız
projeler ilerlerken bunu sunmayı
kusturma ihtiyacı doğdu sunum yaparak
müziğimizin 2019'da kurulmuş olan
kenaroğlu Etnografya Müzesi'ni Bir de
Avrupa dünya sahnesine çıkarması için
hayaller kurmaya başladık
bir yandan ilerlerken hayatımdaki ikinci
taşla tanıştım o da empati her ne kadar
kolay bir kelime olsada çevremizde belki
en az yapılan işlemlerden bir tanesi
olarak görebiliriz aramızda belki GTA
isminde bir oyun oynamış olan olabilir
özellikle genç arkadaşlarımız çok kısa
bahsedeyim boyunun eski oyunun
özelliklerinden bir tanesi nedir Eğer
ana karakter siniz sağınıza O yüzden
burada bir belki yürüyen bir insan
görürseniz sola dönüp tekrar
döndüğümüzde o kartlar kaybolur oyunun
henüz o kadar gelişmemiş olduğu için biz
Aslında bunu Günlük hayatımızda biri bir
yapıyoruz bir daha karşılaşmayacağız
için o kişiyle o kadar değer vermiyoruz
ki karşımızdakine hayatımızdaki birçok
kapı bir sürü birçok Fırsat Bu yüzden
kapanmış oluyor yoldan geçerken yavaş
yürüyen kişinin belki kaybolduğunu
düşünmüyoruz ya da önümüzde duran
kişinin yorgun olduğunu ya da servis
yapan bir kişinin neden yüzünü
gülümsemediğin arkasında Belki çok
önemli bir ilişkisinin bittiğini
düşünüyoruz ya da işten kovulduğunu
karşımızdaki insanlara aslında insan
olarak görmüyoruz Sadece bu oyunda
arkanızı döndüğünüz zaman kaybolacak
olan karakterler olarak görüyoruz ve bu
empati eksikliği de hayatta başarılı
olmanın Belki de önünde duran en büyük
engellerden biri olduğuna çok inanıyorum
empati ile birlikte sorunların devam
ettikçe hayat devam etti yeni bir işe
girdim dünya çapında bir sosyal medya
platformunu
Bu çalışmak için ilanda yerleştim ve
burada da yine sunumlar hayatına devam
etmeye yer almaya devam etti Yeri geldi
Müdürümün doğum gününü kutlamak için
Yeri geldi farklı kültürlerden gelen
insanların kültür günlerini kutlamak
için videolar yaptık paylaştık ve 16 bin
kişinin dünya çapında çalıştığı bu
şirkette ödül alan beş kişiden biri
olmamı sağladı yaptığım işler gerçekten
çok ufaktı ama aslında içinde bulunan
şey birinci sunum ikincisi yine empati
ydi Bu da yeterli değildi sunumlar
hayatında çok büyük yer aldığı için
dedim ki girelim üniversitelerle
buluşalım öğrencilerle bir araya gelelim
onlarla kişisel markayı konuşalım
kişisel marka ne demek ismini nasıl
duyulmasını tutsun bunun önemi nedir
hayatında kariyerinde kişisel hayatında
aynı şekilde Networking önemi neden
küreselde ismimizi uyması gerekiyor ki
herhalde de aynı etkiyi yaratabilirim
bunu öğrencilerle paylaştıkça onlardan
güzel yorumlar geldikçe sunum yeniden 12
yerine güçlü bir şekilde almıştı bize
büyümeye devam ettim hikayelerimiz şu
aldım gönüllüler artık çalışma kurulumuz
üretim kurduğumuz tamamen Gönüllülerden
oluşan hocalardan ekonomisine matematik
cisinden fizikçi sini herkesin farklı
fikirlerini değerlendirerek müziğimizi
büyütmeye ve geliştirmeye devam ettik
fark anda gördüğünüz son çektiğimiz bir
sahiplenme hikayesi belgeselinden birkaç
görüntü buraya salladı birlikte
hikayemizi güle güle taşıma amacına
ulaşmaya başladık bu da yetmedi birde
Avrupa müze formunu düzenlediği
Avrupa'da yılın Müzesi sil at ödülünü
kazandık 2021 yılında bu ödülü kazanan
bize olarak da gerçekten yerelde olan
etkiniz birden bire büyümeye başladı
arkamda gördüğünüz annemle babamla
köyümüzdeki evimizde yaşadığımız ödül
gecesinden bir görüntü pandemi ile
birlikte tabii ki Fazla etkinlikleri
Online'a geçiş gördüğümüz dönemde böyle
bir anımız oldu ve ishal ya da bile dün
Ama siz gereken yerimizden biroğlu
verdik Anadolu'da başlamış olan bu küçük
direnişin birden bire uluslararası
boyutta böyle bir Karadeniz'de kazanması
Bizlere çok şükür Ümit verdi Aslında
yaptığınız için ne kadar büyük değil ne
kadar emek verdiğiniz ve verdiğiniz
mesajın öneminin ne kadar büyük olduğunu
görmüş olduk İrlanda gittik ödülünü
teslim aldık ödülümüz bağlı taşıdık ve
daha sonra da birazdan paylaştığım
esonya gittikten sunumlar açısından
baktığımızda belki de en büyüğünü geçen
hafta bugün hariç yaşamış oldu kes 17 27
ülkeden 60'ın üzerinde müzenin katıldığı
Avrupa yılımızı s2022 ödül törenine
konuşmacı konuk olarak davet edildik ve
burada yaptığımız sunumda Belki de
aralarında seyircilerin arasında beton
Müzesi'nden bürosundan Milano tasarım
Müzesi'nden dünyanın aklınıza gelecek en
büyük müzelerinin tasarımcılarının
direktörlerinin ve
rezervlerinin olduğu etkinlikte biz
koleksiyonundan bahsetmedik nasıl
sergiler yaptığımızdan da bahsetmedik
sadece Hikayemiz den bahsettik Neden
yaptığımı bu ve ne yapmak istediğinizi
bahsettik ve inanın çok güzel bir tepki
ile karşılaştık Dolayısıyla Bununla
birlikte umuyoruz ki müzemizde Birlikte
Anadolu'yu Bayburt'u ülkemizi en iyi
şekilde temsil etmeye de devam edeceğiz
sunum ve empati benim hayatımda iki
büyük taşı oynadı adım adım ilerleme
sağladım henüz yolculuğumun çok
başındayım Umuyorum ki bu taşlar benim
irade yine başarılı olmamızı
sağlayacaktır empati dediğimiz de her
zaman karşılıklı düşünmeye kendimi
teşvik ettim ne ister ne isterler Ne
duymak istiyorlar anlattığım hikayenin
onlara katkısını olabilir onların
anlattığını bana ne katkısı olabilir
Bunu her zaman dikkat ettim sunum
dediğimizde sunum sadece Elimizde olan
bu kumandayla sahneye çıkıp yapılan şey
kesinlikle değil Fuaye alanında yeni
insanlarla tanıştığınızda çayınızı
içerken yaptığınız sohbet hafta sonu
yaptığınız planda nereye gidilmesi
gerektiğini ikna ettiniz arkadaş
gurubuyla yaşadığınız o sohbet hocanız
anneden sunulan iyi not almanız
gerektiğini kendinizi anlatırken finalde
yaşadıkları ne dersin sınavından sonra
başvurularınız mülakatlar hayat boyu
yaşadığımız bütün et enfeksiyonlar
aslında birer sunum dur Dolayısıyla ben
nasıl olsa sahne çıkmayacağım videolar
çekmeyeceğim gibi düşünceler yaşasak
Aslında sunum Hayatımızın her yerinde
olduğunu katıl atmak bir defa daha
istiyorum bir adım budur süt sebeple
yazdım buraya az önce bahsettiğim gibi
ben sunum Empati kurarak yap adımlarım
attım ve gerçekten her zirvenin nerede
olduğunu Bence kesinlikle önemli değil
önemli olan dünden bugüne ve Bugünden
yarına bir adım atabiliyor Sak Zafer
bizimdir Teşekkürler Arrow